Before we start, let's go over some basic concepts.
What are Blueprints?
Well, Blueprints is Unreal Engine's visual scripting language.
Now, it's important to know how this came about.
Unreal Engine runs off of a programming language called C++,
and C++ is text-based and relatively complicated to learn.
Now, when you're working on a large game or any other program,
there is a likelihood that you're going to have a mix of people that are going to be working on it,
and not all of them are going to be programmers.
So this is how Blueprints were born.
They are exposed pieces of code,
which can be placed within a flowchart-based graphical interface
that allows you all of the power of C++,
just in a much simpler, more graphical way of understanding.
So when you've got level designers, or artists, or texture artists,
they don't have to go away and learn C++.
Originally, it was relatively limited,
and only a few nodes were actually exposed to the Blueprint system.
But over the years, it's grown to be a lot more robust.
At this point, there are some computer games that are almost entirely coded within Blueprints.
It runs, in some cases, slower than C++.
However, for most people's purposes, it is sort of unnoticeable,
unless you do something wrong.
Now, C++ is an object-oriented programming language.
So what does object-oriented programming language mean?
Well, in simple terms, it means that all of the code is split out into objects,
and these can contain both data and functionality,
but it's designed to make everything easier to manage and reuse.
So you don't have to create hundreds and hundreds of different pieces of code.
You can just reuse the same objects, but in slightly different ways.
Within the engine, we will talk about Blueprints,
and we'll talk about classes, and we'll talk about instances.
Now, a class serves as a template for something that you want to create,
and can be seen in the Content Browser.
So you can see it here in pink.
We have the third person character.
This is the class, the Blueprint.
But if you were to drag this into the world, it would create an instance.
You can see three of them here, depicted by the blue arrows.
An instance is what you get when you drag a class into the world.
Now, each of these instances can have its own settings and variables,
even though it originates from the same class.
And we're going to work on this here in the exercise a bit more.
But if you imagine an NPC class or a enemy class,
that might have...
You could have hundreds of instances of the NPC within the world,
but they might all have their own health,
or they may all have their own strength, or some other different variable.
But that needs to be tracked by instance,
and not something that's going to be held within the class.
The other concept that's important to understand is inheritance.
When we're working with an object-orientated language,
everything inherits functionality and sort of values from its parent class.
So within Unreal Engine, we have, and especially within the editor,
we have a class called Object, or within C++, it would be UObject.
Now, this is the highest class that you're going to work with.
Within the editor, pretty much everything you'll ever work with
will be a child of this object class.
Now, this object class has some definite benefits to it.
We'll go over them in a second.
Any of the functionality and data of the object
is then going to be given to a child class, in this case, such as an actor.
And that can have extra functionality,
and that will be provided to every child below it.
But there's this concept of inheritance.
You will be able to reuse the code from the parent class,
and this makes it easier to manage and extend functionality,
as all the child classes, they can have additional features or code,
or they can override the functionality that they had.
Now, here's a good example case.
If you jump into the engine and you're asked to pick a class,
some of the most common classes are going to be listed as actor, pawn, and character.
So first of all, we have the highest up class that we can have,
and that's the object class.
And the object base class in Unreal Engine is the highest up one,
and it has some functionality that we're not going to worry about much here,
but there are things like garbage collection and low-level coding,
things to make life just simpler for you that you don't need to worry about.
Now, a common class which is a child of the object class is the actor class.
Now, the actor has the ability to be spawned into the world,
complete with a transform for positioning.
So an actor has the ability to exist within the viewport.
Anything that is in the viewport will be a child of the actor class,
and this has the transform attached to it.
So you would see that in the details panel,
but the transform just has a location, rotation, and scale
that will allow placement in the world
and will help us to be able to do things like render it out
and figure out collisions and so on.
The actor has the functionality of being able to exist in the world
in a specific location in the level.
Now we have the pawn class.
The pawn class is a child of the actor class,
and this has the power to be possessed and receive input from a controller.
Now, this doesn't necessarily have to be a player.
Usually it would often be a player controller,
but it could also be an AI-controlled character.
So it has the functionality to be possessed.
But as a pawn, it is also inheriting all of the functionality of an actor.
So it's getting the ability to exist somewhere in the world,
and the actor is getting the functionality from the object.
So things like garbage collection.
Garbage collection is just cleaning up the memory
as you go along so that the game runs smoothly.
And the final class we're going to look at here is the character class.
Now the character class includes a skeletal mesh and a movement component,
allowing for an easy setup and animating a controllable character.
So this has extra functionality, and they're actually components.
So the character class has inherited from the pawn class.
So the character class has got movement and skeletal mesh.
But from the pawn class, it's got the ability to be possessed.
And from the actor class, it has the ability to be placed within the world.
And from the object class, it has got garbage collection.
It's another low-level coding we need.
This is how inheritance works.
Whatever class you have can inherit functionality from its parents.
It will by default.
We are not going to go over in here, but you can also override functionality.
So you can create a child class,
which has actually got different coding from its parents.
You can have multiple children of a singular class.
So for example, in this case, the object class has an actor component and the actor class.
But it could have lots and lots of different children,
which all have different functionality.
And then those below them can have more children of lots of different classes.
So you can see how her system can get a lot more complicated.
But because this is all object-based and class-based,
it means if you write the code in the correct place and create children accordingly,
then you won't have to do a lot of rewriting.
You won't have to manage code in lots and lots of different places.
You can just have the functionality you will call written in singular places.